yeah i've never been able to get over
that podcast well no i just did it again
why two weeks ago why do you keep
sitting in your car
oh my god the last time was when a week
before you were here too
it's like a sign that there's a sign
that you're coming
yeah yeah yeah so you picked it up and
it looked like my face
it's like oh no but there's just
something there's a there's a connection
between you
and just [ __ ] in my car stuff in
your car
i couldn't stop you're not old enough
for that yet
it's not acceptable at this age yet ten
more years maybe
i couldn't stop yeah you can stop that
no but
this time around he pooed in a bag
this time around so i'm really proud
yeah i'd say that's a weird thing to be
proud about
clean up look if i don't have to clean
anything up i'm proud
baby steps can you not sense when a poop
is coming
no because um what happens is uh if i
drink if
so what happened was this okay we i woke
up late
a little bit and we got to get in the
car she has a doctor's appointment right
okay so what i do is i'll
take i'll smoke a cigarette really
quickly and i'll drink black coffee
that's the worst combination right so
worst combination and i'll just go one
right in the car usually you know when i
wake up and i do that
right um i'm playing video games right
so i can push pause
and just go right to the bathroom but i
have emergency shits all the time
right but in the car and it happened why
do you do it sometimes it comes
um just out of nowhere it's not out of
nowhere
you did you you in you took in a deadly
combo
of the cigarettes yeah but that
combination
generally sometimes it happens sometimes
it doesn't right so it's 50 50. but
don't take the risk
it's happened multiple times now i know
so i'm in the car
and right and i felt fine though you
feel fine you're like i feel fine
and all of a sudden i had this great
urge
right it was like i couldn't stop and i
tell her
time time tables in the car i go
two minutes yes it's two minutes and i
was like well it's two minutes to the
doctor's office so
[ __ ] wait yeah so i waited two
minutes but alas
it's the time covered so they rejected
him at the doctor's office and said you
may not poo here
oh yeah you're covered poop yeah and
then you have to make decisions so i
[ __ ] right in my pants
so i went right in the car on la cienega
i would just go gutter
[ __ ] that well you're from the
philippines
so what do you find sexually attractive
about it
let's let's let's segue into that room
what is this what is your sexual desire
[Laughter]
the fact that he has absolute
like love and freedom like he he loves
himself
the fact that okay because i dated a guy
before maybe like a little bit before
him
super hot super built super tall
whatever correct correct proportions
right human being
but he did this thing once where i after
that i was like i never want to sleep
with this man again no like he took a
shower and he came
out and like he did this like cover his
dick thing uh
when he was like shy he was like don't
look and i was like oh my god
well that's very unique that's not a
normal thing either that guy's a [ __ ]
weirdo
and i was like but i i i i did
yeah he owns up to it and then he'll
like yeah he i remember the first time
we hooked up like
he would do things like he would be
naked with his belly out and he would
play the air guitar in the corner just
naked
yeah what the [ __ ] is this dude doing
yeah yeah he's mental and i like that
this is a perfect match made in heaven
no but i i i think that
everyone should be like that oh 100
authentically yourself
right and i generally try not to
apologize
you know you should learn he should
learn so far
no but like um hey guys we're gonna take
another really quick break to share one
of our most